hey whats up guys mkbhd here with a
long-awaited high-definition video
review of the as a hurricane 2000 full
tower ATX case this is a computer case
that is definitely going to be used by a
lot of enthusiasts who are building
their own pcs like me and this was
actually one of my top choices when it
came to picking a case so let me first
give you guys a hardware tour of it
first we can go ahead and check out the
top here I'll zoom in a little bit you
have one two three four five and a
quarter inch hard drive bays then we go
ahead and zoom down and behind these two
fans on the right hand side here you
have one two three four five and you
can't see the sixth one at the bottom
six hot-swappable hard drive bays those
are all the hard drive bays and they all
have a module behind them so you can go
ahead and release today just by pulling
it to this side and taking it out and
you can see these are all sturdy babes
are all made of a nice carbon and
plastic composite so this will be great
for any baby plan to install in here
I'll put the top of the case we have a
couple of other things I need to show
you on the left hand side you have two
USB 2.0 ports audio in and out a USB 3.0
port and an e SATA port at the top you
also have your power and reset switch
this case is called a hurricane 2004 its
extreme air moving abilities this case
happens to move a lot of air and that is
thanks in part to this side panel which
causes two huge 230 millimeter fans as
part of the cooling system sure that
does make the two windows a little bit
smaller for looking into your case but
this isn't really a showcase this is
really for moving a lot of air and you
can see that this is fully enclosed in
its own separate enclosure which is
really nice for a side panel taking a
look inside the case itself you can see
the drive bays at the top there and
moving down to the bottom you see all
your hot swappable drive modules
including the two bottom ones which I
figured out are not actually hot
swappable you solve a lot of room for
hard drives though those are your
rainbow tables that are coming from the
front io ports which have your USB three
pointer to point o and all those two
things that are all house right there
and they are used utilizing these cable
management holes that are at the top
over here there right there and there so
there's a lot of room for having your
cables behind the motherboard tray to
give you a lot of room
for airflow through this case you also
have a lot more stuff for air cooling
you can see at the top there are these
spins that sort of jet out the case like
this and those house to 200 millimeter
fans at the top which is a lot of top
exhaust for any full tower case over on
the left-hand side here you have a
hundred twenty meter 120 millimeter
going out the back and one hundred and
forty millimeter going out that side the
case which I'll show you in a minute you
also have your motherboard standoffs
which are already on the case and you
have seven PCI expansion slots for your
graphics cards sound cards USB cars and
things like that at the bottom you have
your power tray which are you can
obviously mount your power supply on
there's these four rubber grommets they
can keep your power supply elevated and
that's especially good if you're
mounting this something a case like this
on a carpet or floor you need a little
bit of room for the fans to blow out the
interior of this case is also a really
nice black they did a good job with
making the whole case black so if you
have a nice black and brown setup going
on like I do is definitely going to
match your setup and really stays
neutral in an office like this with the
case turned around to the back you can
see their rubber feet that it stands on
the bottom mounted power supply to order
cooling grommets on the right which I've
air cooling holes around them the seven
PCI expansion slots next to it there's
the place where your motherboard I oshio
will go and the place where the back
facing fan is and these two are the two
fan controls for the 2 200 millimeter
fans at the top I wish those were in a
more accessible place but it's still
nice to have and then at the top you
have more cooling and another water cool
and gromit the entire side of the case
behind the motherboard tray is nicely
protruded so you have enough room to
hide a lot of cables behind there even
if you do have you know a lot of
graphics cards and all the things you
need to write back there there's enough
room in that side of the as a hurricane
2000 k so you'll have plenty of room for
cables and you won't have to worry about
having cables in the way of your airflow
still looking at the back of the case
here you can get a good idea of the
airflow that you're going to get with a
case like this with the fins pointing
out the back and still pointing a whole
lot of air right out the top of the case
that's all the hot air coming off the
top and it's really nicely directed by
these fins above the case that also add
to the style of it which look really
good looking from behind into the front
of the case here you can also see that
there are four of the hot swappable
drive so any of the drives you put in
those four will be hot swappable
long as you connect them with those SATA
and power cables properly and the other
that are below those hot swappable drive
bays are just permanent days so you
won't be able to take them out I
personally don't use hot swapping that
often I typically leave a solid state
drive in and two solid a regular hard
drive for storage but this is always a
nice feature to have and I definitely do
appreciate as including it a case with
this many fans and this much air cooling
is definitely always a really nice thing
to see air filters or dust filters on
large fans like this and those are
definitely present both on the power
supply tray in the bottom and over here
in the front five and a quarter inch
base with the mesh on the front you also
have dust filters so it's really nice
that as it includes these with all via
the mesh and see through parts of the
case they'll all have dust filters so
you won't get anything nasty in there
overall the hurricane 2000 cakes by as
oh really did impress me an is one of my
favorite full tower cases as it does
have support for all types of
motherboard sizes and things like that
and I really did enjoy it so the pros of
this case I'll start off with the pros
it does have a lot of airflow almost
excessive airflow so if you're using hot
parts like the high-end i7 or the
higher-end AMD chips you're going to
want to use these or if you have a
really hot graphics card and things like
that this case is definitely going to be
beneficial for you and the cons of the
case well if you look up the dimensions
it is a pretty big case so if you don't
have enough room for this in your setup
you might want to look for a smaller mid
tower case or even a smaller size full
tower case but make sure you have enough
room for your parts so if you really
don't have a size limit and you really
want to go all out with a high airflow
high performance case then may I suggest
the as a hurricane 2000 this is an mkbhd
with a high-definition video review I'll
talk to you guys in the next one thanks
for watching peace